e
e e
we'll wait a minute for um represent
Bailey to get back with whatever he was
looking
for uhuh there it
is all
right okay I'm going to open the
subcommittee work session we'll start
with uh Senate Bill
488 and
um this was the
one about
um well there's two parts to it one is
it gives the Authority for uh the
um I believe the board to Define their
continuing medical education
requirements and um as I understand
it and Doug can correct me if I'm wrong
um to initially become actually why
don't you come up yeah yeah to initially
become a uh PA they have to um have
passed a
test um from the nccap the uh National
Commission on certification good morning
we just started 488 Senate bill just
started just started right that um to
get their initial license they have to
have passed the exam from the national
Commission on certification of
Physicians
assistance um which I'm guessing they
actually
um that means they're getting their
certification from them but they're not
required to maintain it assume the nccpa
has their own continuing requirements
education requirements if you're going
to maintain certification but because
you don't have to um there needs to be
some other method of of defining what
the continuing education requirements
are and this directs the um the board to
do that through rul
making and that's uh am I correct in
that introduce yourself that's my
understanding of it yes sir just
introduce yourself for the oh sure uh
Douglas oer how general counsel oplc
okay um and then the second part is
another exception for the barberan
cosmetology for the Pas as it is there
for Physicians and and my understanding
in there is that like you know if you've
got a boil or some wound on your scalp
let's say and to treat it they've got to
cut the hair remove the hair around it
that's technically barbering so this
gives them an exception so they don't
have to go out and get a barbering
license to do it um and uh I had noticed
that there was um another part in
statute that had something to do with
continuing education and Doug has sent
us information indicating that that's
not a problem if you can just review
that for everybody
else and if anybody else has questions
or issues with this and before we do
that you have something
represent
Moody thank you thank you Mr chair
um my question is
it's when they're preparing somebody for
surgery and if they have to remove the
hair why would Barber come into a
because if you read the barbering statue
to cut someone's hair you have to have a
barbering license correct that's under
normal circumstance this is a medical
thing and they go to school for but
still currently on the way the statute's
written technically the positions
assistant would have to have a barbering
license this removes that it it's just
makes it clear that that's ridiculous
and is not
required because you know what's written
is written and those are the rules and
um and I think having thing having you
know legal requirements that aren't
enforced is not a good idea it can cause
problems and it's better just to clean
up the statute which is what this is
trying to do
agreed makes sense certainly uh
representative Brown uh thank you Mr
chair um and represent of maputi under
under the statute 13 313
a25 those are exemptions to barbering so
it's exempting those people from the
license but Physicians assistants aren't
in that exemption list right now right I
I think my guess is when uh physicians
assistant you know when that was created
they neglected to add them as an
exception along with the Physicians and
this is just cleaning that up oh just a
follow up Mr chair uh repres yes yeah um
so the way I'm thinking through this is
there is a statue and physician
assistants were not included in that
statue in the exception in the exception
to the statute that's there yes but they
are regulated currently by by the
medical board which the doctors surgeon
and nurses are exempt from that correct
right so isn't that part of
the reading if they are they're part of
that pack in creating that if I can
answer I mean you're you're talking
about you know I guess statutory
interpretation so how do the statutes
get read and how do they interact
and I think the issue is the Board of
Medicine has no authority over the
practice of Barbering they the Board of
Medicine cannot provide an exception to
the barbering statute right um just like
they can't create an exception to
Plumbing license or whatever and so
that's up to us and so if there's going
to you know yes it's silly to say they
have to have a barbering license but
that's the way the stat the way statu
interpretation the way you'd read the
statutes says they would have to have
that license that's a problem and this
is intended to fix it okay if that yes
there's no sense leaving a gray area
when we can fix it right right I mean
you know Prosecuting a PA for cutting
the hair on somebody's head to stitch up
a wound is not goingon to I mean you
know any prosecutor to Tred to do that
would be looked like an idiot but it's
still better to have the statutes be
correct uh representative G
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
spill
proof my question is why did this come
to
subcommittee uh this came to good
question it's my fault I apologize um
this came to subcommittee because I saw
in
uh a thing that was in the
uh 328 D colon one Roman 1- a already
had some language about continuing
education and I had a concern that
having it in statute and then also
giving the authority to the board might
cause a problem so I asked uh Mr
osterhout about that and he came back
and believes it's not a problem and I I
agree with that and I'm going to let ask
him to explain that and what I'm hoping
is if everybody's okay with that
explanation I am that we can uh just get
a motion for OTP on this and you know
move on y so Mr oud sure um I mean I
have the email in front of me yeah but
I'm not it was wasn't entirely clear to
me partly so if you could explain what
the thing
is uh so you asked me to look into the
definition that you identified what was
that 328 D1 uh Roman numeral 1 a yep uh
defines approved continuing Med medical
education activity we were concerned
there was some conflicting language um
I'm basically just going to use my email
as an outline and explain it so um under
the Board of Medicine rules 60401 an
applicant for initial lure as a
physician assistant must submit as part
of the application documentation that
they've passed an initial examination
administered by the
nccpa um it may be confusing because I
don't believe the Gen Court website has
been updated yet and so if you go to the
oplc website you can find um the newest
rules adopted by the board and just to
put this out there that's true with any
of the boards if you ever I would always
do both and just cross reference the
most up to date are going to be on the
oplc website um so it looks to me like
there isn't actually a requirement to
hold nccpa certification but it might be
implicit in having passed the exam it I
said it doesn't appear relevant to this
analysis uh maintaining certification
was a requirement for renewal of
physician assistant lure under the old
Med 60801 B5 but is no longer required
for Renewal under the newly adopted Med
60801 so it was a requirement that they
I understand that and that's the why
this bill is needed there there's more
okay sorry carry on
sorry uh so so my opinion was I think
under I'm just I have to read because I
looked at this a month ago yeah I think
under the current statutory structure
the board can already and already has
set renewal requirements for Pas that
haven't maintained
nccpa uh 328 D1 which is where this all
started does give the board approved
continuing Med medical education
activity language but it also part of
that definition is any other board
approved activity so my response was
that I think everything is in place to
accomplish what s488 is trying to
accomplish as far as not requiring nccpa
certification for PA renewal and I don't
think that definition conflicts as it
pertains to CES other than
nccpa okay so the board can come up with
whatever continu education requirement
they want regardless of 1A that's the
way I'm reading it yes sir okay any any
other question yeah represent M py uh
thank you um
so my question is
NC
AAP all the acronyms alphabet soup that
I have to memorize um but so that is the
national you start out with and that's
Universal for all states
correct uh because if you have a
national I'm just drawing a parallel
when I had the Asha certification
American speech and hearing associ
iation certification for Speech
Pathology and ideology for a while
unless I had the CCC for ideology and
Speech Pathology I could not get any
license to any state Massachusetts New
Hampshire whatever so that was the
prerequisite and initially it started I
had to have license I mean certification
as well as the membership then it got so
expensive that they dropped the
membership you can be a non-member but
you still have the certification that
was the stamp of approval the national
level so you're saying with the
physician assistant that stamp of
approval at the national level is no
longer required to get the state
licenser it is required for initial lure
it's not required to renew that license
so every two years you don't have to
renew it and you don't have to
pay H so is this done in other states I
wouldn't know
that that that could come to bite you if
uh you're in a
bardy
professionally um any other comments or
questions about this from the
subcommittee yes uh representative Brown
uh thank you Mr chair sorry I'm I may
have misunderstood
you what what you said a few minutes
ago that it wasn't in 1A that the board
has the authority to do any other board
approved activity but I'm seeing in onea
that the
board as uh as the attorney said that or
any other board approved activities at
the
end no I'm not sure what my question is
about that I misunderstood what you said
I thought you said the opposite of that
no no I I just saw that there were some
specific things related to contining
education and we're giving the board
authority to Define them and um I just
wanted to make sure there wasn't a
conflict and it appears there's not and
so I'm fine with the bill as is
representative G and then Mony thank you
Mr chair I'd like to move off to pass on
Senate Bill
um well we'll get the motion in a second
then uh and then would someone like to
second I'll second I will second that
and uh um representative Gould on your
motion I think that um the explanation
we've gotten on any possible conflict's
been uh clear in that there's not a
conflict and that the board will be able
to handle whatever um rules it needs to
make okay U representative Brown you
want to comment on your
second uh uh no I think you covered it
thank you and the discussion
represent M py um my only question or
concern would be it's still the Pas are
under
Physicians rul making or Board of
Medicine as the rulle making
and how would that
impact if the next one that's not you
know the one that passed the house in
terms of not
having supervision trying to
independently work
so there there there is a dichotomy
that's being created I I don't see that
I mean they're still under the Board of
Medicine uh just that specific
requirement was dropped but the Board of
Medicine will still have the authority
as I understand it to set their
continuing uh education requirements and
uh and dog do you have any comment on
that
I just want to remind everybody that the
requirements already been removed
because the the rules went through the
rul making process and they were passed
at the jail car they've been adopted so
that that requirement is already gone to
remove the collaboration maintain the
certification oh certification correct
but I mean there's no conflict she was
talking about the continuing ad the
collaboration agreement requirement and
that's a separate I think that's beyond
the scope of the continuing education
piece okay I would have to look at the
language I didn't I didn't look into
that for this yeah all right okay uh
representative gold as I recall in that
other Bill the physicians's assistance
if that bill passes will still have a
board supervising them one way or
another so that whatever board is
supervis medicine right and so that
board would still handle their
continuing education requirements that's
my understanding
yes representative
Bailey I was just wondering what this is
some section of exceptions or something
which part the I mean a through L must
be something right this is just a new
sub paragraph under some section I think
if I may I I've I've gone away from it
but it lists all those
other uh others that are exempt from
that doctors and nurses she's talk she
he's talking about um the first section
the continuing education thing is an
m so that's in 28 d10 uh Roman
1 uh my guess is it's other things where
they can do rule making d10
yeah he's got it here he's got a
pad okay uh Roman went
so um it's the other stuff and there are
other areas where the uh board is G is
uh required actually to adopt rules so
this is just adding to the sort of rules
that the board is is required to uh
create and goes for rule making thank
you uh represent m one last question for
clarification if the
doctors have the exception this would be
very similar to the doctor's exception
are talking about the barbering or
barbering and also the you know that
only Pas that are
in Surgical
well it's it's not a primary Family
Practice well it would be any PA it
would apply to I mean I mean this is
just off the top of my head just to
guess but I mean there might be reasons
other than surgery where they need to
remove the hair let's say you look like
you've got a serious uh skin problem and
they need to take a better look at it
have to remove their hair I don't know
if that's the case but any any reason
where they would have to remove hair as
part of providing whatever treatment
they're providing this would let them do
it
do you you hang on so I mean I'm
following through the chain like yeah
dermat the position yeah the groups that
will come in uh contact or has to make
those decisions not
every every field in the doctor's uh I
mean in the medical field will have to
do that ER well Dermatology it all
depends it depends on the circumstances
of the case if it's a case where to
treat it properly they've got to remove
some hair then this allows them to do it
we're not going to get into the details
of when they can and can't remove
somebody's hair I don't no no no I'm not
saying we need to but I'm just saying if
it's already established for medical
field it shouldn't be difficult to
replicate or duplicate that rather than
trying to create another exemption this
isn't all if you read the language all
it takes is the existing language say
Physicians and surgeons licensed under
RSA
329 when engaged in the practice their
profession that's an exception from the
barar and all it does is ADD and physici
assistance licensed under RSA 328 all it
is is expanding no the existing
exception to Pas as well as what's
already there for others that's fine I
please yeah and and thank you Mr chair
so to follow up it I guess if it said
the the medical field that would be a
generic category that could include a
physicians assistant but they're all
very specific Physicians and surgeons
chiropractors medical or surgical Office
of the uh Department of Defense nurses
morticians so it's very specific so
because it doesn't have a generic
category you'd have to make this a
specific addition right and then General
statutes have to be reasonably specific
because in the end if somebody were to
challenge them you know it's got to be
laid out so a court can you know come up
with the correct
interpretation and so you know saying
General things and and saying well you
know having that requirement wouldn't
make sense doesn't mean we don't need to
make it clear in in statute that the
requirement isn't there uh
representative
Bailey I I don't know if you find it
amusing or ironic that through this New
Hampshire would come up to the Middle
Ages and we we could have Barber
surgeons um well it no actually not
because if when engag in the practice of
the profession which is being a physici
assistant and just doing General
barbering is not engaged in the practice
of profession their profession and
therefore that the exception wouldn't
apply then so no we don't sorry that
could be a bill for next year uh and any
other
discussion okay so we have a motion of
ought to pass by repres G second by
representative Brown all in
favor anyone opposed and we got one two
three four five of us all right thank
you all right I'm going to close the
subcommittee work work session on Senate
Bill
488 and uh once I get work next we're
going to do
um going to open the subcommittee work
session on Senate Bill
and just as a a a
recap This was
um so there was the
creation of
um licensed pharmacy technicians which
was done recently in the last couple
years I
think and um I guess the the idea the
point of this bill is that if they're
going to
be um overseen by the pharmacy board
there ought to be
um you know they have ought to have
representation on the board and so what
the first part of this does is increase
the size of the pharmacy board from 5 to
seven members uh adds an additional
practicing pharmacist and adds a
um a pharmacy technician that's the
change to add that and then the part
that was uh and then down
below there's currently a requirement if
you look at it that the uh pharmacist
members the board shall have been
licensed pharmacist for at least 10
years and at the time of their
appointment practiced Pharmacy in the
state for at least 5 years but I guess
originally there was no requirement on
how long the pharmacy technician be
licensed and uh so this bill as I
understand it was put in for that
purpose it
basically
um in effect duplicates that um but the
problem was when this was written the
bill was written it only listed uh
certified pharmacy technicians but since
there are also licensed pharmacy tech
technicians um you
know I think I think we need an
amendment that says uh licensed or
certified um and then as I recall there
was some discussion during the uh
hearing asking whether or not the
requirement of them being Li you know
being a pharmacy tech for 10 years and
in the state um for five years there was
concern that there might not be a large
enough pool
uh because the pharmacy techs you know
sometimes go on to do other
things and um I asked uh Mr osterhout
about that and um he actually sent me a
list of all the licens all the they're
not just licens or registered Pharmacy
tax of which there are
1674 total and there are 42 who've been
licensed in the state for over five
years and I also talked with the um the
sponsor of represent Merchant who is a
pharmacist I think he's on the board at
least he was I think he still is was um
and you know he doesn't believe there's
a any problem with the pool being large
enough that would meet that requirement
to have candidates on the board so uh
his recommendation was to leave the 10
and five and I'm okay with that so um
you know what I'm proposing is oh he
also wanted because of uh current
membership of the board and phasing it
over and the fact that the licensed
pharmacy tech that whole thing's new and
there's very few of them he wanted the
effective date change to January 1st of
25 which again I don't have any problem
with that and so you know
um I'll make a motion that we can have
discussion and my motion is that we make
those two changes one is um that it be
uh licensed or certified in uh on line
19 on page one and that we change the
effective date to January the 1st of
2025 so second okay and any uh
discussion on
that yep represent M py thank you Mr
chair um I do like two things one is to
add the pharmacy technicians because
they are more in almost all uh
pharmacies now they are using pharmacy
technicians so they have the
representation the other one that's
interesting is the hospital pharmacist
that's a whole different um group of
Pharmacists so this I see line
three and one of whom shall be a
full-time Hospital pharmacist that's
that's existing language this bill does
not change that
okay and one so we are going from five
member board I mean yeah five member
four me five member board to seven in
general the uh yeah it's good to keep an
odd number so you don't get
ties and I guess the decision was made
to uh add one of both a pharmacist and
then add the pharmacy technician and and
if I might in the original Bill Mr chair
it was six and somebody caught that and
changed it to seven oh the in the Senate
yeah okay thank you one more followup
with that um is there a difference
between the time required for licensing
versus certification for f receive Tech
um I don't know how that's relevant but
uh I assume there's additional education
and exams and all that um dog if you he
doesn't he doesn't have the details but
okay but I would expect there would be
but I don't
know um any other
discussion it's adding one pharmacist
and one pharmacy
technician I think I think the my guess
would be that uh you know they want to
keep a good majority of Pharmacists on
there um whereas if you added um two
Pharmacy texts it would be four and two
and at least the author of the
bill uh didn't think that was the way to
go the one
not the one the one being
add only the
technician well they're already there
that's existing language they changing
the number number four to five
right seven two right and and what
they're doing is they're they're they're
going from four practicing pharmacists
to five of them and they're adding one
pharmacy tech and that's the two yeah
but that only adds up to six 5 plus one
is six no no no no it's it's uh you're
you're having um no five it's four
instead of four members it's going up to
five no no it's going from 5 to
7 it's going from four pharmacists to
five
Pharmacists and then they're adding oh
and there's also a public member in
there okay that that's what it didn't
the numbers didn't make sense yeah
there's also a public member which stays
the
same any other discussion okay um so the
motion is to uh create uh an amendment
and I'll go down to Olas and arrange for
that um after this but to make um those
two changes to add the uh cert licensed
or certified on line 19 and to change
the effective date to January 1st 2025
all in favor I anyone opposed all right
now we need to have uh I'll make the
motion and that's um ought to pass with
that Amendment on the bill and I need a
second okay second
R um do we need any more I don't I'm not
going to say anything more about it I
think we've covered it representative
Gould anything nope I think you covered
it any other
discussion all right all in favor anyone
opposed no all right very good so we're
so you're going to get the amendment
yeah okay and that would be a different
number we don't have that we don't have
the amendment um what'll happen is I'll
get that Amendment and I'll send it
around to the full committee and we will
deal with that next week on the 8th when
we exec the bill
so all right so I'm closing the
subcommittee work session on Senate Bill
600 and then I'm going to open the
318 and it's actually the um the
non-gain amendment to that
bill and
um just as kind of an overview what
happened this
bill was I think uh on social work
compact originally the language is
identical to the house bill which we
already dealt
with and so um and if you
remember all the time some of us spent
on House Bill
1271 which changed a number of boards to
advisory and
merged um aboard and um also got rid of
the uh the pharmacy Tech
registration um you know there were
objections at the last minute to do
making some of those board's advisory
boards and so that bill was interim
studied but um there wasn't oppos you
know there was support for at least some
of them and so what representative
Maguire did is she presumably talked
with other people came up with a set of
boards that there was hopefully General
agreement on moving to advisory and also
the uh you know merging the the massage
and the reflexology and that was at the
request of those two boards and they're
already advisory those two and then uh
dealing with the pharmacy technician
issue and
so I'm I understand it what she asked OS
to do was take those sections from
1271 apply those sections of the
amendment proposed amendment to 1271 and
then create out of that non-main
amendment to Senate Bill
318 and
um I I asked I you know I figured ol
hopefully could do that correctly um and
I asked uh but just to be safe I asked
uh attorney aser how to verify that and
it turns out they did a uh I'll be kind
and say a really lousy job and um and he
and actually I'm going to hand some
things out here
so I've got um Doug's comments on that
here's I already gave you one so four no
I got them I I print a number of them
one two three
four oh no I've got
plenty I know but if you're interested
hand that down to her so these are uh
Glenn take one and pass along please I
think there's enough and that that's um
you know the input I got from
dug on that pass that one down you've
got one already and then I went through
it to make sure I understood them all
and kind of wrote up my uh my take on it
I had a few questions which I'm going to
ask Doug about and pass this this down
as
well and then if anybody needs it I do
have some copies
of of the original 1271 the amendment we
came up with 12
1271 and the amendment to
318 there a short one uh the second one
all right here you
go the amendment to
318 okay and if you want the other two
or anybody else wants them that's fine
okay so uh I'm going to work off the my
email back to
Doug and
um so
I think Doug if if uh I understand
correctly you're you're you indicated
there was the first one is one where I
didn't see what you apparently saw uh I
found the language in there later and
just didn't update my thing so we can
ignore the first bullet okay in my all
right and I'll go through the others for
people here and when there's questions
I'll get back to you on that and if
anybody has questions let me know
so um
the second
bullet is um basically it's a situation
there was a
language
um either I don't remember it was either
in the bill or the amendment 1271 they
just left Parts out and so um 1271 as
amended um added a definition defining
uh what what the board
was uh the ne and the rest are
similar well almost all of them there's
a couple exceptions um the third
bullet and um it's another case where
they left out um a definition of who the
executive director was and all of these
were either in 12 well they would have
been in 1271 as amended if we had done
that so they were either in 1271 or in
the amendment to it uh fourth bullet
item
item is the same thing they left out
that whole section duties of the
Advisory
Board um the last bullet on that page
and then going into the next
page um this is getting to the nursing
home
administrators and again it's a
definition that was uh that OLS left
out um this the um first bullet on that
second
page um
yeah there's a whole section of uh
language that they just didn't carry
over to the
amendment
um second bullet on that
page
um Doug actually I
think so Doug on that one um maybe I was
wrong but I I didn't think what you
noted covered everything that needed to
be carried over but I may not have it
right we're on the second bullet of your
email on the second page all right so as
hb1 1271 as
proposed got a lot of documents floating
in front of me so yeah I know um page
34 on
which section on the bill as introduced
I'm I'm following I'm just trying to get
to where the language would
be okay thank you are we here uh line uh
line uh 20 and and I can pass around
copies section
yeah okay so it looks like in the
languages proposed on page 34 of we of
the original House bill of the original
HB 1271 yeah that's it starting at line
72 there were some Amendment made to 151
SE 72 yeah sorry
yeah yeah 1 two 3 four I know
uh yeah actually one I I the way this is
going I'm gonna hand these out so um and
I've got enough so
Diane I got everything here already
already got it so Mr the chair yep and
so just I have like three different
copies ofb
318 s SP 318
FN well the original s SP 318 we're not
dealing with at all relative to adoption
of social works so that's going away and
then there's an amendment uh Amendment
1429 H which
is yeah and I have 1271 in my okay fine
yep and yeah I have the amend did I give
[Music]
you okay so this I'll just pass these
out and if this is a duplicate which you
have just keep it get rid of it whatever
you want um so that's the set of three
which you can hand to somebody who
doesn't have
them um pass that on those three to
whoever needs
them they
have all right so don't
all right so I I'll hand hang on hang on
please stop don't touch those here's
1271 and the amendment to 12 you're
going to get me 1271 and the amendment
to
and and do we have another anybody else
need
one
okay I should have this 71 I'm making
sure she has one all right
two different ones you gave them two
different ones 1271 and three the
amendment the amendment to
1271 and that's page
34 yeah yeah I think that's what he
meant the to 1271 or to 318 I've got
that which one the 127 one itself but I
don't have the
amendment okay 318 you can pass this
I've got plenty okay good I had HCS
working on thank you than because I
thought this might get I was hoping we
would just uh say oh we approve it but
apparently says it's fine no no chck
double hey as as you recall when we were
coming up with the amendments to 1271 I
there's some things I didn't catch
so all right um
when people are organized let me
know so we're on as far as the second
bullet we're working off three documents
is actually what's going on so um what
Doug's talking about right now is hb1
1271 is introduced starting at page
34 and we have two different amendments
well one amendment is 318 which is the
the 1 to 38 1429 H uh correct okay not
uh okay 1248 H is the amendment to 1271
127 so what all what all us was supposed
to do is take things from the bill was
introduced particular
section apply the changes in
1248 which was the amendment to that
bill and then create from that an
amendment to
318 but they did not not
do yes definitely a lot of stuff got
left out
actually thank you I I spent uh yeah
part of yesterday doing that so okay
back to
you all right so I'm on page 34 of House
Bill 1271 as introduced section 72 yep
so the committee made some
um the language there makes
modifications to
15183 yeah then in the amendment to 1271
the March 20th
Amendment paragraph one was changed
there so I think the intention is to
take you know you have the page where
that is so people I
don't just I didn't write it down for
some reason and that was the uh to on
the amendment to 1271 you're saying the
amendment to 1271 so there are no 3 page
34 in that no that's in the that's 34 in
the bill is introduced yeah but where
the nursing home administrators were in
the amendment to
1271 yeah the problem is we're dealing
with three different um page 19 okay
actually if we can keep together on them
that'd be good yeah I didn't write down
the um so it's page
19 of the amendment to 1271 so I think I
think the intention is paragraph
one R numeral one for 151 D Aon 3 what
line are we talking about should well
I'm talking about all of them now 22
line 22 22 22 okay so I think the
intention is we want the language of the
amendment to
1271 and then two Roman Al 2 on as
introduced to be the language that ends
up in Sp
318 okay that's right including the uh
strikeouts and all that including the
strikeouts everything okay just so we
stay in sync on the amendment to
318 where is this is this in here at
all I believe it was left out the whole
thing's out the whole thing's
out okay so we're not going to find it
probably all
right okay so
that's and if anybody has questions
about any of these let me
know um Mr chair uh represent G I have a
question you said um Roman numeral 2
Roman numeral 2 in hb1 1271 as
introduced so it would be 151 d a colon
3 it's on page 34 line 20 line 20 CU we
modified all of the language to
15183 I just was so we just want to swap
out paragraph one for one I just wanted
to make sure I was on Roman numeral 2 in
the right document yeah the point is the
amendment has a change to Roman
1 yes yes on page 19 of the amendment to
1271 line
22 20 starting at 20 really but great
that that was the langage that's Roman
one correct so we want to take basically
all of the section
on
um all of
section I put it in my email 73 but it's
actually
72 yeah it Ser I should have said 72 I
believe in my email on that
bullet um we're talking about bullet the
second
bullet but there's also
73 replacing section 73 with the nursing
home administrator oh yeah no it
was right on my second bullet I have 72
but then I when I got to looking at the
on the first
bullet first bullet dealt with section
one and then I got down to the second
bullet and I started looking at more and
I think I realized that um the problem
was
larger and I think that in addition to
the problem with Section
72 I think they also missed
um which we needed and that's and then
they saw the amendment also addresses so
we need the original language then the
amended language for 73 is well I
believe um actually it is in it is in
318 Amendment what page it is in 318
Amendment it's page five at the bottom
line 35 functions and duties of the
Advisory Board
um if I'm if I'm understanding
everything we're talking about see
that's
um representative I have it identified
as in the 318 as well section 73 bottom
of page five uh section 13 of 38
yeah and that's what was in
73 compared the word yes and we're
including any Amendment from the
amendment to 12 correct so that that did
that did make it okay when I was trying
to dig through it it looked like there
was a problem but I'm not
surprised okay so my comments
on the
second the my my latter comments about
section 73 are not correct which I'm
perfectly willing to believe but you had
uh but what you had there was the issue
with section
two um and the
issue so is the issue with section two
that that's it's not in 318 Amendment
not in 318s Amendment so this has to be
added all right and just to let people
know what to try and make
sure we get the right thing out of OLS
this time um my plan is to take a copy
of uh the 318 Amendment and edit it with
the changes were you know they're on the
sheet that we talk about
today and then send it to Olas and also
send it out to everybody here so yep I
represent M py yeah thank you I just
have a fundamental question in terms of
how line
35 which document uh
amendment to HB
1271 page 19 page 19 Y Line 35 and it
goes into office of professional lure
and certification in consultation with
the board and if you go up the same page
yes um to provide say line what uh line
22 yeah um
implementation of this chapter shall be
transferred to the executive director of
The Office of professional licensure and
certification um wasn't that like it was
given to the office of professional lure
and certification not to
individual um in that
office wasn't that that that still is a
conflict I feel I might may not be
looking at I don't know I what do we end
up where do we end up I I mean
technically I think Lindsay testified
that you have to assign the
responsibility to an individual which is
why executive director is probably true
but I will or more accurate but I will
say as an executive branch attorney I
don't think I don't think there's any
confusion if if the responsibility is
assigned to the office I think that kind
of trickles down to the executive
director and trickles down further to
their designes so while one may be more
correct than the other I I think we're
okay with whatever you land
on so just to clarify the whole
discussion during the entire uh
committee at
1271 was you know this is a much broader
than one individual and that was that's
what my recollection is if it's not
accurate that's fine but that's what I
want to make we went we went back and
forth on that um I think the way things
are interpreted if it's assigned to the
executive director that doesn't mean
they have to do the work because they're
in charge they can have anybody in the
department in the office do the work but
they're responsible to make sure it gets
done is what I recall represent gou
thank you Mr chair even though to me
this this whole debate is potatoes and
potatoes the the office seems to be what
will draw the least criticism and so my
recommendation would be to just change
it to the office and move on in the
amendment I mean I don't I personally I
have no opinion on this okay so um so
what you're asking is that we change it
to uh transfer
to uh the office of and so I the
executive director of would go away yeah
all right just for consistency's sake
yeah I don't
okay fine represent Brown thank you Mr
chair it would be nice if this would
match all the other things we changed in
in language I think that's the
conversation we had we're trying to make
each one of these laws have the same
words in them for consistency so I
forget where we ended up I thought um I
think we ended up here and here kind of
right yeah I
mean if we catch ones here I I really
personally don't want to go through and
try and find everyone again again no uh
at this point but um I have no objection
either way so I'm I'm fine making that
change so just just so that you know
that's what my notes kept saying that
was my little pet peeve from day one in
terms of uh
1271 and uh that was kind of debated
heartly debated yep and the consistency
was arrived at that all right that's
fine okay great thank you okay on page
two of my email the third and last
bullet um which is uh this one is I CL
got a number of sections so the first
one
um so there was a line in effect a line
left out about repealing RSA 151
a63 um and Doug is that correct
and that and that's
from
um that's that's correct there was some
technical language that was in the hb1
1271 amendment that did not make it to
318 what page was that um it would have
been page 21 of the amendment section
79 okay that's right it's it's technical
clean up kind of so yeah so that's uh
language page 21 of the
amendment line line uh line 20 through
okay um I do I think you
may I put 20 through 28 just for the
renumeration language as
well okay that's missing is well
actually I I dealt with that uh the next
one oh okay down um Tony I don't think
the renumeration I think that can go
away entirely because we're we're
getting rid of every that's only related
to the registration medical technician
that whole part we're going to get rid
of correct because which I'll talk with
people because the Senate's dealing with
that so I think the second sub bullet
under that last main bullet there on my
email
um I indicated that I don't
think um
the whole 888999 all that stuff I think
can go away I agree with that I don't
have do anything with that right
okay um and that
gets
right yep okay so that's fine I'm going
to the next page the last page of my
email um there's um
two bullets the first one if you look
back at um at Doug's original
document
um
page the heck is that uh page
243 oh
no oh wrong wrong document too many
documents here here we
go um
page okay
page right uh is that right there was a
whole big chunk of text that was left
out
um related to combining the two advisory
boards so that was just
completely they included a little bit
about it but then they left most of it
out so um thank you for catching
that um and then the last one is
um
318 uh be 318 page
10 that's the amendment to 318 be clear
um and
that's sections 20 okay so
this so what what section and if you
look at the last page of the amendment
to 318
um 24 to 25 that's got to do with um
getting rid of the registration of
medical
technicians um which we did in House
Bill 1410 but more on that in a minute
and so
24 remove 328i which defined the medical
technicians removed it from the list and
then uh 25 repealed it basically and
things that related to it U but what's
happened in the Senate I introduced that
bill to the Senate
uh Senator Carson wasn't happy with
getting rid of the medical technicians
she worked with
oplc and they uh they came then the
problem if people remember there was
that um none of the medical technicians
well one at one time were interested in
serving on the board so they never had a
quorum so they never made rules so oplc
could never do anything and so the the
amendment I think that Senator Carson is
proposing would uh get rid of the board
and transfer for the Authority for
registering and disciplining and all
that medical technicians to the
office that's am I my understanding
correct that's accurate okay and
therefore if that's gonna that bill is
already changing this area so we should
pull that out of uh the amendment to
Senate Bill 318 so there's not a
conflict so okay which which bill is
changing that sorry uh there's 1410
House Bill 1410 which um passed this
committee and pass the house the Full
House it then went to the Senate and the
Senate is looking at um is planning to
amend that okay got it to change how
medical technician registration is
handled to instead of having a board
just have the office do it since they
can't get anyone to serve on the board
so take and So to avoid a conflict we
need to remove anything referring to
that from the amendment to Senate Bill
318 which are sections uh uh 24 and 25
thank you Mr chair uh represent M py
yeah um question is in terms that was
completely eliminated in 127 121 1310
correct 1410 Y and uh because was also
if I under remember correctly medical
technici comes
under
LNA of
licensing there's no separate licensing
they are not licensed at all it was just
registration yeah but the rules on the
way the the thing was set up originally
the there was a board created that would
do rul making to do things like what are
their requirements to be registered and
they would handle uh adjudication on any
disciplinary issues and things like that
but for them to do Ru making they need a
quorum and since they couldn't get
people to serve on the board and never
had a quorum there were no rules and if
there were no rules then oplc couldn't
enforce anything so also wasn't that
during that discussion was you know
there's no field called medical
technician that was the quandry that the
whole thing was they didn't view
themselves as a profession therefore
that apparently because of that they
weren't interested in serving on a board
and therefore the whole scheme didn't
work and so the Senate's looking at
changing it to get rid of the whole
board structure to have oplc handle the
registration and any complaints directly
and to give
oplc the rulle making authority to make
rules with regard to that so just a
another one quick followup with that one
is this was very specific instance what
happened in exitor hospital with uh
right uh and to not have that happen
again in our state was this was I
believe that was was uh Senator Sherman
who pushed that through he was involved
in that situation and some of his
patients or people he ended up
treating
um and so he was behind the creation of
it unfortunately the method you know the
scheme they came up with turned out not
to work and it needs to be changed and
and uh you know whether whether the
registration is a necessary or whether
my whether the registration would fix
the original problem I have questioned
but I'm not going to you know that's not
involved in
this for House Bill 1410 removed it
entirely as part of
1410 well because house housef 1410
passed the house it does not pass the
Senate and because the Senate is decided
they don't they want to do it
differently their intent is to amend
1410 to move the authority from a board
to
oplc I don't have any big objection to
that and as I let them know and uh so so
assuming that's the only change they
make to
1410 then presumably they'll pass it
that way and it'll come back to the
house and we'll probably Concur and and
that's how it'll be handled is my my
prediction so in the Senate Bill there
there is no Senate bill on the Senate is
going looking at amending the house bill
okay so why is 118 I mean 318 I'm sorry
we're replacing the entire 318 so the
original 318 is not
relevant but the amendment to 318 we're
using 318 as a vehicle to pass part of
what was originally 127 yeah is what's
going on and
so um when they wrote this amendment we
didn't know the Senate was going to do
what they're going to do and so they
included in here the um the repeal of
medical technician registration in this
but we don't want it here anymore
because this would conflict with what
the Senate is trying to do which which
would cause pointless trouble so when I
so what I'm planning on doing is the
stuff we've discuss Chang we've
discussed I'll edit 318 the amendment to
318 sorry and send it back to all us and
what I will as part of that I will
completely remove sections 24 and
25 okay because this this because I
don't want to repeal something the
Senate's going to change okay that would
that would be
problematic that wouldn't make sense
right good
sign uh I don't want to go
[Laughter]
there and then Senator Carson would hate
me more than she does
but she's my Senator I joke around with
her um okay
so any actually how about this I'm going
to I'm going to I'd like I'll make a
motion and then we can have further
discussion if people want and that is um
is that
um that I'll come I'll take what we've
discussed here I'll create it um I'll
change the amendment to 318 to go along
with what we agreed to I will send it
out to
everybody um I think there's enough
time I don't know if I'll get it done
today because I got a stuff for tomorrow
but um and then we got session
I'll create it and I'll send it off to
all us I'll also send it to you folks
and uh if you have a chance look it
over uh hopefully I'll get it right but
if not then I'll I'll have all us do an
updated
Amendment and um so that that's my
motion uh we have a second second
okay Mr chair y if I may just remind the
members of your subcommittee that once
they receive that Amendment you
shouldn't Tech technically be discussing
it via email a violation of right all I
how about I understand that not not the
answer is if I send that out and you
find a problem do a reply don't do a
reply all and if you think I made a
mistake just let me know and if I I
don't agree I'll have a conversation
with you and once that's settled
probably you'll be right but once that's
settled I'll update it I'll send it out
to everybody for further comment but
again and you're thank you for that
point um just do a reply to me reply not
reply all otherwise we're we're breaking
the rules so look out for your email by
Friday yeah I'll try and get it before
but given or over the weekend
tomorrow yeah right just have have that
timetable in and and uh and when I when
I do get if there aren't any changes
that people ask for when I get the
actual Amendment from all send it out to
the full committee because we're going
to be executing it on Wednesday next
Wednesday
so okay so basically what you're saying
is give the input before Wednesday exact
session so we'll have the right
Amendment well well enough well enough
before that I could actually get OS to
do a redraft yes which I have no idea
how long that's going to take at this
point but all right um all right so um
all in favor of uh what we just
discussed anyone opposed
and then I guess
formally
um does anyone make I I'd like a motion
for
otpa sure on the result of it G I don't
know who did it first but I think she
beat me to
it I don't
care um and so um all in agreement of uh
passing the bill with uh the amendment
we just described I any anyone opposed
okay thank you I'm closing the
subcommittee work session on Senate Bill
318 and we're done for the
day no no that's tomorrow at
10: you should have gotten a
notice
yeah
okay and
um there have been some discussions um
that I've had with Jackie and
Carol about this and
um my what I need to do when I go yeah
about 440 yeah we're talking about for
this is we're done now this is just some
uh discussion about fut housekeeping for
the sub
subcommittee um so my intent is to put
together at least a a proposed amendment
to
440 and I will try and send it out not
too late
tonight um and then tomorrow we will
we'll work on that go through it see
what people think and um if there's you
know there may be some questions still
deal with it and then hopefully tomorrow
we'll come up with a you know what what
you know again I can't predict the
future but I'm hoping we'll come up with
a uh an amendment we agree on to 440 and
I'm hoping that we'll recommend on to
pass with such an amendment and then
I'll do the same thing I'll go to Olas
and to draft it and I will then send
copies out to everybody so so I do have
one from oplc draft
legislation Amendment for
440 and I do have that was that the one
that came out when it
I've got many things uh page one and
two it came on the
22nd let me put this stuff away here and
with
uh I mean we're not I don't want to get
in too much into no no no I'm just
saying we have something should we take
a look or just ignore as I'm not going
to tell you you you're welcome to ignore
it I'm not going to tell you you're not
allowed
to look at it no it makes sense in what
it saying so that's why right but but I
will I will send something else out okay
um
that Amed by it was your testimony on
the 22nd and it had the amendment Lang
proposed
amendment after that yes all right so
purely clean up um yeah I think I think
the deal is this I think the Lang yeah
that's you're you're uh bring it's
coming back um so I think the deal is is
that oplc found some technical issues
with 440 and so what they're proposing
is that fix that's not what I've been
talking with with uh uh you know with uh
representative groa or or Maguire anyone
else but I think you know we'll look at
that and if it looks I haven't looked I
haven't l i saw what it was that it was
a technical correction I haven't looked
at it in detail but assuming the
subcommittee is fine with it we'll add
that into what other other Amendment we
come up with for um I don't know about
you all I've been getting a lot of calls
from both op and email and all that hey
I'm being harassed by my opthalmologist
so uh when he calls me during dinner I
call it harassment
is turn your
off
y
e
e for